سحر هاري بوتر ، أنت ساحر ،
ينقله هاري إلى طوكيو ، إنه في
هذه المنطقة الضخمة حيث سيشاهد المعجبون
بعض المجموعات الأكثر شهرة مثل
القاعة الكبرى في هوجورتس
والغابة المحرمة ، وهي جزء من
استوديو وارنر براذرز الجديد الذي سيتم افتتاحه قريبًا  في
اليابان ، ما يدور في ذهنك عندما
ترى القطار ، ترى
المجموعات التي ترى فيها الأزياء ،
لا أستطيع تصديق ذلك ، وعندما أتيت إلى هنا ،
يجب أن أتذكر أنني هنا في
رحلة عمل وليس  عدم
النظر إلى هذا الأمر كما لو كنت مجرد معجب ،
جيف ناجلر هو رئيس
عمليات استوديو وارنر براذرز في جميع أنحاء العالم ، لماذا
اليابان
أعتقد أن هذا كان أحد أسهل
القرارات بالنسبة لنا في الواقع بسبب
الاهتمام العالمي الكامل بهاري بوتر
بعد يونايتد.  الولايات وبعد المملكة المتحدة ،
اليابان هي ثالث أفضل
منطقة لعشاق هاري بوتر ، تم
تصميم استوديو طوكيو على غرار الاستوديو في
لندن وسيكون أكبر
رسمًا كبيرًا لقطار هوجورتس السريع
الذي تم تصنيعه في لندن ونقله
برا وبحرا إلى موقعه الجديد.  في المنزل هنا في
اليابان ،
لا يتعلق الأمر فقط بالمجموعات ، بل يتعلق
بالإكسسوارات والأزياء والدعائم
مثل تلك التي شاهدتها في الأفلام ،
لا يمكننا عادةً رؤية ما يحدث
وراء الكواليس في الأفلام ولكن هنا
نتمكن من رؤية  كيف يتم صناعة الأفلام ، على سبيل
المثال ، يوضح لنا كيف يعمل الأشخاص الذين
يعملون في فيلم الدعائم الدعائية للأفلام ،
تعمل جميع أقسام المجموعة كفريق واحد
لمحة عن فيلم Magic بعيدًا عن
جذور هاري بوتر في المملكة المتحدة ، هل
ترى آسيا كسوق نمو
لتجارب مثل  هذا بالتأكيد
ننظر إلى الصين وننظر إلى اليابان ،
وننظر إلى كوريا الجنوبية ، ولدينا قاعدة جماهيرية كبيرة
في أستراليا ونيوزيلندا
بالإضافة إلى أنها ليست كلها في آسيا ، إنها
قصص الخيال الخاصة بمنطقة آسيا والمحيط الهادئ بأكملها والتي تجذب
الجماهير في جميع أنحاء العالم  مارك ستيوارت سي
إن إن طوكيو